la contraofensiva ucraniana no sólo tomó
por sorpresa las fuerzas rusas estos
soldados ucranianos tampoco pueden
creerlo
pasamos al ataque y tomamos una de sus
posiciones la ocupamos la fortifica mos
tres días después el frente se movió y
todos empezaron a dispersarse y
estábamos preparados para luchar pero no
esperábamos que abandonaran todo el
frente
ahora se dedican a reparar los vehículos
enemigos abandonados
si se puede desenroscar se está en los
rodamientos debería desenroscar sé
que este es un camión rural ruso de
nueva generación todo preparado para su
invasión bueno ahora estará trabajando
para nosotros
hay evidencia de la derrota rusa por
todos estos hombres están revisando una
antigua posición rusa encuentran cajas
de municiones cohetes pm 21 grados
aparte del armamento los rusos huyeron
dejando algunos recuerdos culturales
lenin playboy y otro pino y algunos
periódicos de aspecto claramente
soviético como consiguió ucrania un
éxito tan espectacular según andrew y
malakoff uno de los comandantes es en
parte gracias a una campaña de
desinformación antes de la
contraofensiva ahora se está recuperando
de las heridas de bala sufridas durante
la operación
todo aplicados y un
dirigiera asalto mi principal maniobra
fue un ataque de señuelo al sur de
valaquía en realidad el ataque principal
procedía del oeste nuestra inteligencia
difundió la información de que el ataque
vendría del sur enviaron muchas tropas
allí cuando comenzó el ataque matamos a
200 de ellos el primer día y bloqueamos
sus contraataques no lo olvidarán
y
lo que hace que el movimiento sea aún
más notable y malakoff es que las tropas
rusas en la región de jarquil superaban
a las ucranianas en una proporción de 3
a 1